we're asked to rewrite the following two
fractions as fractions with a least
common denominator
least common denominator so a least
common denominator for two fractions is
really just going to be the least common
multiple of both of these denominators
over here and the reason the value of
doing that is then if you can if you can
make these a common denominator then you
can add the two fractions and we'll see
that in other videos but first of all
let's just find the least common
multiple so the least common
let me write it out because sometimes
lcd could meet other things so least
common
common denominator
denominator
of these two things are is going to be
the same thing as the least common
multiple of the two denominators over
here the least common multiple of eight
and six and a couple of ways to think
about least common multiple you
literally could just take the multiples
of eight and six and see what their
smallest common multiple is so let's do
it that way first
so multiples of six are 6 12
30 and i could keep going if we don't
find any common multiples in this out of
the this group here with any of the
multiples in eight
and the multiples of eight are 8
24 it looks like we're done and we could
keep going obviously 32 so on and so
forth but i found a common multiple and
this is their smallest common multiple
they have other common multiples 48 and
and and 72 and we can keep adding more
and more multiples but this is their
smallest common multiple their least
common multiple so it's it is
it is 24. another way that you could
have found that least common multiple is
you could have taken the prime
factorization of 6 you say hey that's
two and three so anything that is any
the least common multiple has to have at
least one two and one three in its prime
factorization in order for it to be
divisible by six
and you could have said
what's the prime factorization of 8 it
is 2 times 4 and 4 is 2 times 2. so in
order to be divisible by 8 you have to
have at least 3 2s in the prime
factorization so to be divisible by 6
you have to have a 2 times a 3
and then to be divisible by eight you
have to have at least three twos we only
have or you have to have two times
itself three times i should say well we
have one two now let's throw in a couple
more so then you'll have another two and
then another two so this part right over
here makes it divisible by eight
and this part right over here makes it
divisible by six if i take two times two
times two times three that does give me
24 that gives me 24. so our least common
multiple of 8 and 6 which is also the
least common denominator of these two
fractions is going to be 24. so what we
want to do is rewrite each of these
fractions with 24 is the denominator so
i'll start with 2 over 8 and i want to
write that as something over 24. i want
to write that as something over 24.
well to get the denominator to be 24 we
have to multiply it by 3. 8 times 3 is
24. and so if we don't want to change
the value of the fraction we have to
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by the same thing
so let's multiply the numerator by 3 as
well 2 times 3 is 6. so 2 8 is the exact
same thing as 6 24. to see that a little
bit clearer you say look if i have 2 8
and if i multiply this if i multiply
this times 3 over 3 that gives me 6 over
and this and this are the same fraction
because 3 over three is really just one
it's one whole so six two eights is six
twenty fourths and let's do the same
thing with five six
five six
so five over six is equal to something
over 24. let me do that in a different
color
i'll do it in blue
something over 24. to get the
denominator from 6 to 24 we have to
multiply it by 4. so if we don't want to
change the value of 5 6 we have to
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by the same thing so let's
multiply the numerator times 4.
5 times 4 is 20. 5 6 is the same thing
as 20 24. so we're done we've written 2
8 as 6 24 and we've written 5 6 as 20
24. if we wanted to add them now we
could literally just add 6 24 to 20 24.
and i'll leave you there because they
didn't ask us to actually do that